[Applause]
swapping frontline politics in
Washington for a real conflict zone
Donald Trump and Melania visited
American forces in Iraq posing for
photographs at a base to the west of
Baghdad the president even signing make
America great again caps some troops
brought to the event not normal for a
commander-in-chief with his soldiers who
aren't supposed to be political speaking
in a hanger Trump defended a surprise
decision to pull his military out of
neighboring Syria there will be a strong
deliberate and orderly withdrawal of US
forces from Syria very deliberate very
orderly
well maintaining the US presence in Iraq
to prevent an Isis resurgence and to
protect us interests and also to always
watch very closely over any potential
reformation of Isis and also to watch
over Iran the president said countries
in the region should step up to resolve
the conflict in Syria he also said the
United States wouldn't be a global
policeman a comment that will likely
revive concern within NATO over us
commitment to the Alliance America
shouldn't be doing the fighting for
every nation on earth
not being reimbursed in many cases at
all if they want us to do the fighting
they also have to pay a price and
sometimes that's also a monetary price
so we're not the suckers of the world
we're no longer the suckers folks the
president's first trip to a conflict
zone was under the cover of darkness and
with tight security for him and his team
but it wasn't all friendly smiles and
warm handshakes a plan for Trump to meet
the Naraku prime minister was canceled
apparently because of security reasons
and logistics the two men instead spoke
by phone President Trump will be hoping
for positive headlines following his
first visit to a conflict zone but when
he arrives back here in DC he will still
face questions over his decision to
withdraw
all US troops out of Syria especially if
there is any sign of Islamic state
trying to regroup in that country Trump
lost his defense secretary James mattis
last week in protest at the Syria
withdrawal security at home is also on
Trump's mind after a row with Democrats
over funding for a wall along the US
border with Mexico triggered a partial
government shutdown now in its fifth day
if Trump's feeling the pressure he's not
letting it show stopping off in Germany
on his way back from Iraq to visit us
cheap space there more selfies and grins
on display but given trump's desire for
European NATO allies to do more to
defend themselves some may wonder
whether one day he'll seek to bring US
troops in Europe home as well Deborah
Haynes Sky News Washington